so he is he the Andre the Giant of black
born yeah I'm coming for you there does
that be great man I'd cut promos for
them is this it's just jump ahead just
just the Reilly read this tiny fragile
bro you're talking about my previous are
you are fit I mean that's hilarious
is it work it looks like she's pulling a
trunk out of her mouth looking for
anybody she's vomiting up a demon yeah
by memories
got a fun hang today with us
joining us he was like what are you guys
smoking marijuana that's crazy
he's like the people from Comedy Central
are cool your friend James is really
bringing up two kilos of cocaine so you
really did live with a drug dealer
that's right I just need you to would
you say that's right you gotta move
watching cops when they do the
prostitution sting how deep they have to
go and conversate watching the when the
cop is the prostitute that's the best
part cuz they don't want to be too foul
and what they're saying guys like what
do I get he was like do I get to put my
she goes that can all be talked about I
guess around the corner she goes I can't
wait to touch your manhood for money
dude that hot money touching when
they're the customer it's always the
best to go huh I don't normally do this
thing I'm nervous how does it normally
work and she's like well twenty
and for that for $20 they get to put my
penis inside of your vagina watching all
those like hookers at the point in all
those documentaries it was just the
funniest to me to pick up some of the
lingo to be like let me get a half and a
half or four okay
I was like 11 watching free weekends of
HBO learning a hooker knowledge the
suburbs just walking around being like
dude let me get let me get topped off
with a 20 is that not crazy yeah
HBO give you get yo family this whole
free month of HBO and your family don't
know so you managed to five I
find it quick Jay and I talked about my
mom would find out and then she would
just put VHS is in and just hit record
and then label what movies were on oh so
she's Cinemax we have to not beat
my dick for a week after that I mean
this is a real thing like you said him
actually when all of a sudden you'd go
to it it'd be like 55 and you go to 55
and work you
what the can you go to like 56 yo
the Playboy station was a part of cable
editor yeah Playboy TV yep you know it
was it was uh it was a very minut amount
of real sexual and then it was them
naked on cars yeah I like dancing to
order brothers so we literally had to
like choose a night where we're gonna
stay up man I can't sleep we'll just go
downstairs anybody else coming down
right now I'll stay up that way you're
saying like let me get the first yeah
you see you see a detective with the
five o'clock shadow always her
and whoever it was comes back in the
room and he goes third cushion from the
right
stay off yeah tag in yours I paused it
we had gene Simmons on the show but his
wife Shannon Tweed was like one of the
first women that I saw in like those
cinemax movies she was an all but then
you're a chick I had a VHS and I would
pause it I paused it one time and she
was writing the guy and they're always
riding the guy like on his ribs it's
never where the dish it's like there's
like a always a fog machine
but dude I saw I paused it at one point
and he saw the cover up on the lady's
vagina and I was like and I had seen I
don't want to brag but it seemed real
point there's videos like dicks like
tape to the leg or on their chest and
that's gene Simmons wife you guys better
look out this is my I remember this is
she too far back I would definitely
watch some Benny Hill yeah cool so much
to do this is a revelation Christine of
that of softcore mistakes there's always
so well lit to that's a well lit sex
scene and it looks kind of boring I like
an icy pore lit scene I like a nice poor
cellphone style see you know like all my
stuff to be ready like grainy I like a
well lit house that was borrowed just
some nervous businessman that owns a
mansion watching a porn film
once I was filmed anything ever or
especially when I film the first time I
kissed someone on camera I all I think
about with scenes and softcore
now yeah because hardcore porn you get
there's diving in there
yeah but softcore where you really
are trying to be like into the schools
we know it's cool it's like you know you
don't want to go too far or you know
you're not actually yeah but
you're both naked I'm like how the
could use to cuz hey I'm gonna bounce my
dick off your time for a while and rub
your muff on my hip and then I
guess we'll break I think we have to I
think we have to take a union break all
right you guys want me to just like
pounder out real quick and then we'll
and then we'll do a turnaround
[Music]